it appears that after the sad shameful
sinking of the sinister and
sanctimonious Republican replacement for
Obamacare known briefly as the American
Health Care Act Republicans are going to
propose another replacement plan and
it's really really bad it's even more
cruel actually than the first one in
some ways this new plan according to a
study that is now being released could
see premiums rise for people who are
already sick which will lead some of
them to no longer be able to afford
health insurance Obamacare has a
provision that prevents States from
charging people with pre-existing
conditions more money one of the
specific provisions of this new
Republican plan is a waiver which states
would be able to seek to get rid of that
restriction so that insurance companies
within their state would be able to go
ahead and start jacking up premiums on
people with pre-existing conditions and
it would also put back in the Obamacare
requirement that was gone from the
American Health Care Act which requires
insurers to cover what are called
essential health benefits this includes
emergency room visits and regular doctor
visits sounds like great news right well
sort of because it would also put in a
provision that allows states to get a
waiver to opt out of that as well
there's a study from the Center for
American Progress on how much more
people with certain conditions would
have to pay the surcharge in the middle
column represents the additional premium
charges that insurers are projected to
add to coverage of each condition
annually and the numbers are shocking
for example metastatic cancer over a
hundred and forty thousand dollars in
surcharges lung brain and other severe
cancers nearly seventy three thousand
dollars in surcharges these findings are
based on national averages so you know
they're going to vary slightly from
state to state but their guidelines you
could say well but David that's the
Center for American Progress that's a
leftist group we can't trust their
numbers the nonpartisan Kaiser Family
Foundation actually looked at the
numbers and said actually they're pretty
plausible meanwhile the new Republican
plan would keep in place that
phase-out of Medicaid expansion that was
proposed in the American Health Care Act
that would result in 14 million fewer
people on Medicaid I mean just a total
and absolute disaster
how is making coverage too expensive for
people who are already sick going to be
good for anybody
those people will be worse off and
everyone else will be too because those
people will have to start going to the
emergency room for primary care
treatment not paying their bills at
least some of them and then those unpaid
bills will get averaged in to everybody
else's health insurance premiums so
we're all going to end up paying for
that well Trump has long said that is
his American Health Care Act failed yeah
and he would just let Obamacare fail on
its own merits yeah and of course that's
not going to happen by itself but he if
he takes away things like the Medicaid
subsidies from the individual states of
eating tactics like this it very well
could and I think he's hoping that
people would blame Obama and the
Democrats but at this point that's on
you I hope you're right that people
would recognize that I am not yet
completely comfortable saying that and I
still think that there will be an
attempt to push the blame hey listen
Obama care didn't just didn't do well
yes I mean because we defunded it and
modified provisions and started allowing
states to opt out of whichever parts of
it they didn't like but it's all
Obamacare that failed right and
unfortunately as transparently bogus as
that is you know that there are going to
be committed trumpets that will fall for
it and they'll say hey it is Obamacare
after all it's possible but also Trump's
American Health Care Act had a 17
percent approval rating so there's
plenty of people who although they
disagreed with Obama and Obamacare yeah
weren't on board with his new plan yeah
fortunately that gives me some hope that
there are people who are able to look at
some of these issues objectively or at
least somewhat more objectively than
just hey Trump winning whatever today's
episode is made possible in part by zip
recruiter it is tough to find the right
person to hire and in order to do it you
should really be posting on all of the
top job sites which you can do with zip
recruiter with just one click post your
job to over a hundred job sites as well
as social media networks like Facebook
and Twitter with one click you can also
search through zip recruiters database
of nine million resumes you
have to juggle emails or calls to your
office you can use the zip recruiter
system to screen candidates rate them
and ultimately hire the right person for
the job quickly zip recruiter also has
human support staff they're also
friendly if you need anything my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free at recruiter comm slash free
trial
okay that's zip recruiter dot-com slash
free trial to try it free you can go to
zip recruiter com forward slash free
trial